[Music]
why does she get a blaster and I don't
what I know how to use it that's what
I'm afraid of
give it to him we're going in Jeddah
that's a war zone that's not the point
of man would you get found it
I find that answer vague and
unconvincing Trust goes both ways
[Music]
you're letting her keep it would you
like to know the probability of her
using it against you
it's high let's get quiet it's very high
Tim just a fast
Empire's building a weapon capable of
destroying an entire planet they call it
the Death Star need to capture the plans
if there's any hope of destroying it we
want to help all right how many do I
need I'll be there for you the captain
said I had to German chi-wah that we are
dealing with here is immeasurable I will
not fail
the Imperial forces are converging on a
present location
take hold of this moment
the force is strong
tell me you have a back-up plan
may the force be with us
broke one a Star Wars story
you almost got me no welcome Riddhi
pg-13 in theaters December 16th I do it
to protect you
see understand I understand